Schnitzel kann ich nur so sondern auch
so aussehen wir machen skaloppine
alimone und das brauchen wir um sie zu
machen Schnitzel Zitrone Mehl und Butter
nichts anderes halbes Schnitzel unter
Frischhaltefolie und fein und
gleichmäßig klopfen wir wollen sie nicht
ultra dünn bekommen sondern zart und
gleichmäßig Salz und Pfeffer mit ins
Mehl geben und vermischen dann von
beiden Seiten panieren einfach nur
drauflegen und dann kurz ein bisschen
ruhen lassen in der Zeit klopfen wir
weiter Schnitzel sind fertig wir geben
ein bisschen Butter in die Pfanne jetzt
gehen wir die Schnitzel bei niedriger
Hitze in die Butter nach paar Minuten
wenden und gar nicht viel Farbe dran
bekommen wollen vor allem das ist so
schön Tat bleibt auf jeden Fall nicht zu
lange braten jetzt löschen wir ab mit
Zitronensaft einfach oben drauf kriegen
wirklich so ein wunderschönen
sommerlichen Geschmack dran die können
wir jetzt schon rausnehmen ihr merkt
schon da ist schon so eine richtig
schöne Schicht drin die schmecken so
unfassbar gut wir machen noch ein
bisschen mehr Soße dazu bisschen Mehl
dazu Mehlschwitze machen und
Zitronensaft dazu und wir schütten
unsere Soße drüber fertig sind unsere
galoppine probieren wir unglaublich
geile Zitrone Note perfekt für den
Sommer